hey guys today we have tea con burn
stamp multi time YC founder so could you
just start by explaining how you first
found YC yeah I actually found YC cuz I
was on reddit I was I was in graduate
school which meant I had a lot of free
time and so I I was it read it was super
early this is back when like a top post
might have like you know ten points and
this is like before he even had comments
and via that I found Paul Graham's
essays on how to do a startup and and to
me the idea of doing a company was
basically impossible
this is after the bubble or after the
dot-com crash everyone had basically
declared like the web was over like that
that's all done now and so it was very
like Paul Graham's essays were really
the only source that I had found that
kind of said that actually here's here's
the pathway to do it and like it can be
done and I was super interested in that
I applied to YC oh no like really that's
like really on a long shot I didn't
think I'd get in
and so I interviewed in Palo Alto and
although the actual program was still
back in Boston in Cambridge and I got in
so I just dropped out of graduate school
what were you studying physics actually
theoretical physics but I computer
science and econ in undergrad so that
was kind of a small change and so yeah
so I dropped out of her head school and
move moved to Cambridge
and so then yeah me trip and Jared
probably worked on like script for at
least well yeah we work on script for at
least like a year and a half before we
got like real traction on it so this is
back in summer 2006 and what was the
initial pitch for a script like in the
application well yeah so what script was
actually like one of those pivot
companies where like we applied with
different ideas and then like much like
reddit was actually a pivot company
where like it was actually applied for
as something else like just like food
delivery stuff really Paul's like oh
yeah Paul's like I love you guys Steven
Alexis but I hate the idea how about
this kind of thing yeah Steve's talked
about that before and so similarly like
Scribd actually was actually the merger
of me trip and Jared like during YC they
were working on some other projects and
like it was like a Craig's List for
colleges back then Craig this was super
hot so like everyone was trying to do
well much like nowadays everyone's doing
like uber Forex like back then it was
Craigslist 4x glory days on the internet
but but then YouTube sold for over a
billion and people so that was insane
you know oh my god Google overpaid which
totally wrong and so then you two became
a hot one so that that we said like
let's do YouTube for documents like that
was literally like that big and I mean
we'd also noticed this problem where
trips dad who's that who's at the
Stanford med school was having trouble
like basically viewing the documents
like online that that like he wanted to
read and like not he didn't have like
the right reader and like sometimes I
had send my mom like a postscript filed
she'd be like how the hell do I open
this
people were just downloading and then
they needed to download like Acrobat or
she's like if you want open yeah cuz
back then if you have like Adobe Reader
though I don't think that actually
opened up like PostScript files back
then it maybe it did but a lot of
default viewers didn't it just depended
on your OS and what what sort of default
software you had bundled but anyway we
just decided like why don't we allow the
documents to be embedded inside of the
web pages and we started off with flash
but we we had always hoped that we could
switch to html5 which we did much later
and so what was the YC experience and so
summer oh six what was that like it it
was great so this was back in Cambridge
honestly we would never have made it
without that program and I think that's
true of actually most of those companies
and I'd argue probably most of the
companies because without that community
of like like-minded people who are
highly motivated and working on like the
same general like pathways you and also
like people who've done it before like
Paul
Jessica Jay Paul Jay L Trevor and like
Robert who were basically there to like
kind of like know you guys are like
that's stupid like a get back on course
because sometimes we would just go the
wrong way for like a whole week
like before we'd see them let me show
them and they'd say what the hell are
you guys doing and they were and they
were always right is the thing so like
it's I mean it saved us years and the
company wouldn't have worked without
them and so I'll always be grateful for
that
and it was all the batches were small
back then I think scribbs summer oh six
was the second batch so still my best
friends were the people from like the
summer no five and summer oh six batch
in Cambridge like and that's like so
going on over a decade just because
those were the only people I knew doing
startups and like they were the people
I've talked to and it was great because
like one day you'd think with startups
one day you think your company is gonna
fail like you know you think you're
getting sued or something someone's
threatening you and the next day you
think you're gonna sell the Google for a
huge amount like cuz just because
someone some like person and I'm M&A I
accidentally emails you
and so having other people going through
the same thing like they're like that
the twitch guys kind of working on their
stuff which took over a decade and back
then it was Kiko which switched into
justin.tv but like having that sort of
having those people and rounded that
community and then kind of like the
guidance of the of the partners is
probably the only reason that we
survived and so how much money were you
getting from my C at that point it was
not the same as it is now yeah back then
it was fixed it was six thousand dollars
per person so overall we took in
eighteen thousand
Congrats that's huge we almost sold the
company for that lid and so I mean
obviously the money lasted what did you
do with it like people get way more now
yeah I'm always amazed how much people
get now because the seed rounds today
are bigger than like the series a that
Dropbox and Airbnb did with Sequoia
which I think was roughly a millage like
and so like how did you guys spend all
that money usually we accept people run
out but back then we struggle I mean so
for a couple of years I was living on
savings we were basically I was I was
basically living out of Tripps parents
house at Stanford and like his mom was
getting irritated because I keep like
eating all the candy and like I was
subsisting on lean on top like top ramen
and I'd like there whatever food was
available in their cabinets so trip
Jared and I worked for months basically
out of his living room and without the
generosity of his parents to even let us
do that and did you raise after YC or
did not a while back then fund raising
was very very different than it is today
also just the environment and Cambridge
is so much different than the valleys
but back then like the mood was so
gloomy and like startups are over sort
of thing that like it took a really that
there were actually weren't that many
angels around there weren't that many
people who had either gotten who had
exited or like who wanted to do that
sort of thing
I mean now demo days oversubscribed and
such but back then it wasn't like back
then I don't think it was even like a
full room actually and so you were just
basically living off savings like Scribd
wasn't making an MK pretty garde far
yeah I mean if you can somehow if as
long as you can get your rent low you
can live for a long time okay do you
know approximately how long that
actually went well I mean yeah it was
another year after YC so we we scratched
by on that and not I mean being a you
know being a wealthy grad student no uh
so having zero savings like surely any
of us because Tripp had just left
Harvard Jared dropped out of Harvard to
do this so we just really like we really
tried to make every dime count
and so how long did you work on script
yeah so started like like I said summer
2006 I left about five and a half years
later I talked to the co-founders I said
listen I think like if we're not gonna
like to go more b2b like like more like
Enterprise II I think that I should
probably go cuz I'm really interested in
doing something in that space and so
they were like okay cool
that they actually invested in my next
company which was parse which we
basically actually actually so it was
actually two of us who left it was me
and James you from Scribd we James was
actually I think our first higher ed
script and so he and I were close
friends and that's the lar and so we
left and the very next day we were
coding and working on like the prototype
of like what was not parsed it was
something else
we what we so okay pause what was that
idea um there are actually 12 so we made
12 different landing pages well cuz was
so a script we would spend about one
month on every idea and like build out
an app and then test it and that's kind
of why it might have taken longer with
parse we said let's not waste a year
let's make 12 landing pages like kind of
launched them and see if people even
give us an email and b2b products yeah
in things that made money like because I
think can be to see it's much harder to
gauge whether you have a long term
traction or not or if you're
chatroulette or something and so yeah so
we basically had 12 different pages that
we launched like what one was an API for
companies to send gifts to like their
best users because that's Scribd I was
like why don't like send gifts to people
are uploaded like a hundred documents
it'd be nice to do that programmatically
I don't think that even existed oh so
like then we just looked if people
clicked on the pricing page and if
they'd send up and put an email in and
then anyone who typed in into their
email we would email them being like why
did you sign up for this this was a
crappy landing page that we made it like
two hours yeah how are they getting to
the landing page where you do like
outbound marketing for any of this stuff
or hñ was like basically but this is
before product hunt so we it was mostly
show HN
it was it was on Twitter you're doing
show HN landing pages yes like show HN
this service exists actually parcel
launch that way two parts launched as a
landing page really yeah back then it
was called Z stack and we didn't know in
the parse com domain which we only got
later thanks to the strike founders and
stripes CTO and so yeah it's called Z
stack and we launched a landing page
again just we wanted to make sure people
actually wanted this thing because we
knew that from our own experience
building mobile apps at Scribd
at other companies that everyone was
sort of reinventing the wheel redoing
the same sort of like code that like
like push notification type stuff that
really could be generalized and back
then like AWS was kind of just still
very much in its infancy but you could
see the need for like Heroku had just
sold for 250 million to Salesforce so
like the pitch of like Heroku for mobile
like kind of was like a very like I
actually dislike x4y pitches now like
all these now but you're riding those
waves on the mess yes yeah I am a
hundred percent guilty of doing those in
the past and so we we actually I think
might I think the pitch deck I used at
YC at the demo day was yeah it was
Heroku for mobile was like actually the
like title of what what the company was
okay and just stepping back a little bit
what made you decide to go with z-stack
versus the other eleven yeah it was
actually talking to the users so we had
talked to the users but be clear there
was no product for any of them so so
parses more complicated parse was that
parse is actually the merger of three
independent entities so Ilya was a solo
founder in parse working on like a find
your friend's app sort of thing which
like it was very popular at a time and
Kevin wasn't even in YC Kevin emailed
Kevin had been a YC previously and then
was working at Google emails Paul and
says listen I want to get back into
startups like if you have anything let
me know
Paul emails the list like hey there's
this great guy great hacker like you
guys should like talk to him if you're
looking for a co-founder and so James
and I met with Kevin and Ilya met with
Kevin we ended up all trying to work too
therefore for for like a couple weeks
and like just to see if we harmonize I
mean I don't advise people work with
people they don't know but hey worked
for twitch yeah for some people it
hasn't worked for a lot of people yeah
yeah okay yeah okay so what were those
two ideas sending that merged oh yeah so
we were actually more in the payments
space more so James and I were
interested in like recurring
subscription billing space where people
were I mean people still have trouble
like actually getting like recurring
billing working I mean it's getting
better now thanks to stripe but so stuff
for like normal people basically take
payments like that were recurring I mean
we we were still very much in the
ideation phase where we were very happy
to pivot to whatever was kind of
whatever we felt would be like the best
type of like business and yeah and then
basically we also started working on
parse and we basically launched that
landing page pretty quickly into YC and
we launched it on Hacker News ah it was
the show HN it was called Z STATCOM I
think at the time and so what were like
what was the page it was literally a
theme forest theme it was like a nine
dollar theme forest theme that has these
hot-air balloons on it you can still buy
it today and it just it was basically
Heroku for mobile like basically we're
gonna take away the DevOps and like the
the backend like part of it so you can
just focus on like the like front end
like like native you know code and not
have to worry about thinking about like
your database and all that stuff
abstracting it away the our SDKs yeah
and I mean I've used the product before
but just like to be clear for everyone
else who's listening could you just give
a quick explanation of what it actually
became yeah yeah
so parse is a platform that helps you
make mobile applications much much
faster we asked to make it roughly 10x
faster and so normally if you're making
a mobile app you'd have to like write
all of the code that like bet the actual
like DD like Native Client interface on
the phone that the person would play
with but
you'd have to think about how does that
app talk to some server in like Virginia
and then what does it send and then
where's that data going how am i
querying it like how why what happens if
that server goes down so parse took care
of that whole second part of this of the
stack so that you just did the client
stuff you make up like a pretty native
UI we didn't believe much in that at the
time in sort of the like html5 approach
which now is working better but like the
sort of PhoneGap type of thing like week
we bleh we we believe that a native apps
at the time were like definitely
superior in experience and so we just
tried to like abstract away like all
basically like the really hard like kind
of like 80% of stuff that people
shouldn't have to know how to do them in
order to make apps and had you guys
decided that like you wanted to go
through YC again oh yeah we talked to
Paul almost immediately on leaving
script yeah and I was like yeah me and
James have to have these ideas we're not
sure exactly which one we're gonna do
and Paul's like alright well let's let's
let's do this again really so okay so
you applied like kind of blind like
there's no product still well we agreed
with Paul doubt that we would focus on a
company called pipe pay which was a
subscription billing service back then
suspect then billing and payments
companies were super hot like we're like
we pay it just raised a bunch of money
stripe it stripe was famously doing
really well but we definitely never
wanted to eat with stripe so we were
looking for other angles inside of penis
you know that you could do things like
anti-fraud type stuff on payments so
basically like another idea was sort of
funded through YC and then you just
changed it and you brought people on in
the meantime okay that actually happens
a surprising amount of the time yeah
yeah and so by the end of the summer
though your your Heroku yeah where
Heroku for mobile yeah or we I later
switch to AWS removal but basically like
an AWS tailored for developers of mobile
applications okay and so why did you
want to do it a second time
YC Oh
well okay first off the first time we
would never have made it without YC and
that's likely true the second time as
well again it's a largely for the same
reasons as the first time I I still
don't think I know anything about
startups like I'm the more and more I do
this the more and more unconvinced how
little I know and so like having that
circuit having that like community of
people like who are highly motivated
having my first customers there right
there in the batch where I could say hey
like like you're making a mobile app use
this like that's really really helpful
because then then you suddenly get
feedback and then every every dinner
every week you go to them and say hey I
launched this new stuff check this out
and then you know we bring our laptops
and show or doing and then like half the
time it was stupid and their people told
us that we and then we stopped and then
the other half they're like well why not
like expand on this that way and we're
oh because that's the problem you're
having in mobile it's not that how did
you start getting customers afterward
because it makes sense like when you're
surrounded by startups you can just grab
a ton of people and I found parts by
going to hackathons because people are
using it all the time
but how did you get people who would pay
for it yeah so we didn't have pricing
for actually quite a while it was a free
service we didn't know how to do pricing
properly back then like and so we were
mostly focused on can we get are we
making something that's making a few
people really happy like so we would
talk to the developers like who had
signed up and who started using our like
beta you know which started we started
off just basically it's like sending
data to the cloud like - like s3 say and
my talking to the developers and seeing
like do we have a product where people
are really disappointed if we just like
went away which i think is a really good
test if you if you can't find some niche
that is absolutely like fanatic about
your product then you likely don't have
strong product market fit and most of
the times that I've failed in startups
was basically trying to push growth
before I had product market fit and so
we found this core segment of developers
who really wanted to make
native apps much much faster ranging
from like agencies who were making apps
for everyone from like Green Bay Packers
to like the Travel Channel and Weather
Channel and Cadillac who actually all in
the be using parse but like we found
people who really cared about this like
this makes my life much much better and
then we actually talk to them and like
use that we use their feedback to kind
of make the parent look better in in the
ways that like it should be better and
we I mean we actually move really fast
all four of us were coding and so we we
worked and we kept kind of launching
features constantly and we got the parse
comm name thanks to Greg the CTO of
stripe because I asked I was over at
their office and I asked them what was
your guys second choice cuz like stripes
an awesome name and they're like well if
stripe didn't work I mean we're gonna be
parsed I was like that like that's
available and they just gave it to you
or something they didn't own it so they
had they had written a script to email
all the owners of like one word English
one syllable domains like stripe parse
things like that and asked them like hey
were you know a couple people working on
startup you know are you interested in
selling you know most never replied
but like parse and stripe owners did and
so I I once a how much stripe cost but
parse was only 15k cars.com it's not bad
yeah all things considered and so so
going through YC the second time like
what became valuable to you I assumed it
was different than the well first of all
it was like way more people write in
summer 11 right but what was valuable
the second time well again like having
like cust customers or like or the
actual users like inside of the batch
where I could like talk to them
having that community because it
actually gets quite lonely when you're
just sitting there like coding like you
know 16 hours a day or like like even if
you're with the same three people every
day like it's nice to have that
community of other people who are doing
the same thing the partners snacked us
around a bit like no no you guys like
are going the wrong way and they were
they were almost always right
and so we got a lot of good like it kept
us honest about shipping every week like
shipping new stuff not not not being
embarrassed of to ship too early which
is like really really common especially
amongst like developers who just want to
keep coding instead of shipping and so
the the partners device was priceless
but and then and then a demo day I mean
fundraising was a fad was next easier I
can't imagine the fundraising you know -
the YC demo day we raised we were wildly
over subscribed but we only took 1.5 we
stopped there for our seed round and
like we really were able to get some of
like the most like so like some of the
best investors and some of the most like
like kind of like famous like valley
type people and it was like it was
really it was really awesome yeah and
then it was like two years and then
Facebook acquired you guys yeah
something like that
yeah so we started parse in 2011
Facebook acquired the company in 2013 we
actually had M&A discussions with
several other companies along the way
like in 20 like 12 and and early 2013
but we we actually raised our series a
like right after demo day we basically
went and started like raise our a
because we actually thought we already
had basically like enough traction to
start doing that and we and it actually
was a fairly a fairly quick process we
raised 5.5 million from ignition so in
total raised seven million happen and
then we started hiring and we kind of
like we were able to recruit some just
amazing developers a lot of people off
the Google search team for instance
people a lot of developers were
passionate about the problem and like
like working on their on the tools that
solve their own problems so that was
helpful and being such a developer
focused brand also helped us and YC was
great for that being able to like kind
of you know post like hey like we're
hiring lined up like on Hacker News back
then I mean because that's always a
question like I wonder right because
people are looking for those jobs but
you guys are also just looking to find
people so
like what was the effective what were
the effective strategies for finding
developers to come work on parse you
just made a cool product or or what well
we often that we would talk to a lot of
our actual users like something that was
so amazing like engineers who were like
using parse and so even if we couldn't
hire them we could talk to like their
friends but also once we kind of got
like a couple amazing hires out of the
Google search team we just kept asking
every we asked every single hire like
who's the best person you worked with
like who would you co found a company
with and then we would just go to that
person and ask the same ask the same
question like to that person and even if
I couldn't get like that individual I
could like you just kind of kind of kept
moving down the tree yeah and so that
actually worked really really well and
we were able to hire like a lot of like
friends or people we'd worked with
previously so I think I think Kevin had
worked with like several of the Google
folks previously and so like they
already knew and trusted kind of like
like us and we already had we had kind
of a good friendly group that wasn't all
just kind of strangers and we were put
but that I mean eventually we ended up
hiring everyone from like we hired some
of our best people were actually users
of parse like the guy who ran all all
our community and such was actually
making parse apps he had just graduated
and so that was actually another great
strategy hacker news jobs post was a
really good one and I guess that alone
actually worked really really well and
so now parse is like shut down right it
is yes so just the other day I think end
of January
Facebook finally so Facebook open source
the entire project and now there are
actually little companies that like
provide parse hosting much like oh man
really yeah much like the its AWS for
parse yeah well because there's actually
like very little profitable businesses
like all those folks who host WordPress
for businesses you know they can like
because WordPress is an open source
project
now parses - so there are people who
just took over the hosting part of it
and so but the parse team to their
credit like they kept
and working and adding features the open
source project it's really really good
and so there's a lot of people who
switched over who like we actually
helped everyone migrate over from like
from using like our servers over it's
like the open source project and like
how to do that
the company did an amazing job with that
I think it was one of the best shutdowns
of a company that I've seen so often
users are really angry and like but this
was a really graceful long like over a
year notice that we were going to be
shut down open source did write
migration tools to many startups and up
just kind of like closing like oh for
sure yeah that's happened do you think
there's another parse coming down
pipeline like someone's gonna try it
again
well firebase did right so they were
actually in our batch they were a
different company at the time they were
doing like basically chat for every
website so like you know how Apple
website like like how it kind of like
how a twitch has like a chat little box
they were trying to do that for everyone
and they ended up pivoting later into
doing basically a parse again so there
and then Google about them so Google
Google has their own parse and then
Facebook had one so you can use firebase
I guess or parts host this is great
actually
oh yeah into it okay so you didn't go to
Facebook right okay so what happens
after parse what do you do yeah so I was
like fairly burned out after I had no
break between script and parse like
literally it was like the next day I
just started working again
so after many many years I guess I I
always wanted to travel I've never done
so and so I spent about two years
traveling backpack in South America
without a computer which was great like
yeah and I lived in Europe for a while
did a lot of speaking at conferences
that that sort of and I tried to learn
more about the international startup
scene it feels like every city
internationally or a lot of them think
like how do we build the Silicon Valley
of like you know South America or how do
we build this
Valley of like Peru and it's like that's
not really the right approach I don't
think I better off focusing on like
being really friendly like one niche
like we're gonna like we're gonna be
really friendly the Bitcoin people like
we're gonna make the banks be friendly
the Bitcoin startups and like people you
might get more people going there and
not dealing with all like this although
that say like drones have here like with
all the regulations so you could see
like a drone valley I'm like a Bitcoin
Valley I mean stop no I completely agree
with you though right like there's no
reason why like you know all the
pharmaceutical startups couldn't be in
Germany or something and so what did you
learn from like so you're speaking in
all these conferences and stuff and you
eventually stops and doing all that
speaking right did you pick anything up
along the way yeah the number one
question that I got was how do we raise
money how did you do that and it's
really unfortunate because like much
like that like the angel ecosystem that
had to build in Silicon Valley like it
took a long time like back in like even
O six there were not that many investors
and like terms were not good like I mean
nowadays the typical seed ran out of YC
is higher than like the series they post
money that Sequoia did in Dropbox and an
Airbnb so you have to envision like this
client was completely different like
there was not this like flood of capital
chasing like every good startup so
that's kind of how it feels most in most
international areas or what do you tell
people um come out here when I was
telling folks yeah I mean I said if you
can like raising out in the valley is I
mean like like for instance like algo
leo was in Paris the same time I was
there and they ended up moving here
front tapped from Paris also moved here
where front up I'm an investor in and so
the honest truth is like I mean I still
think living and doing a start-up here
is very beneficial and it has certain
downsides very expensive here but in
terms of fundraising that certainly
helps
now also investors are largely averse to
like non Delaware C Corp
like for instance I as an investor now
and like me over 60 or 70 companies I
don't understand like the legal
ramifications of investing in like a
company in like you know South America
so you basically just avoid them well it
just it would be a large like legal
headache to think about to go have my
lawyers review this and see because yeah
so with with the Delaware see corporate
so I I actually just encourage folks to
like it to like apply to like Y
Combinator or if they can't get into YC
apply to like 500 startups whatever but
like these these programs are so perfect
for people internationally and I love
what stripe is doing with Atlas like
helping people they're letting anyone be
an entrepreneur or look around the world
that is such an awesome ambitious goal
and solving that problem so I think
things have gotten much much better than
that when I was like back in like when I
was hearing that in xx like 14 largely
due to the efforts like that and like
well I see this a really good job of
taking like there's a great company
called razor pay that I'm an investor in
that's kind of like strike for India and
you know they like YC helped them with
the whole transition it's super valuable
and so that's probably a good transition
so you said like 60 angel investments at
this point do you have a particular
strategy and area you're focusing on
how's it going yeah so I've been um I'm
so far too invested in like cruise which
just sold a GM gussto lend up checker
Optimizely
reddit things like that for me in the
early stage investing I really primed
the first thing I'll look for at least
is like like it is there a large market
because like without a market it's
really hard to be successful even if you
build a great products and so is is
there a large market and are these
founders like like a really like
relentless team that is like determined
or like I actually have this joke
question I'll sometimes
like kind of I don't actually ask
founders this but like I'm like hey you
know there's this conference and like
you know like in like the UAE and
someone just dropped out do you want to
give a talk killed yeah
and like they were kind of like the
conference's that I was actually going
to and I guess you weren't a founder at
the time but still oh yeah yeah but like
often a founders are willing to take
long destructions and doing things that
are not relevant to their companies
that's a bad sign
and so you you kind of learn to identify
the folks who are relentless well like
what are other signals for you you see
in people I actually like solo founders
I know that's an unconventional thing in
the valley but Dru was initially a solo
founder with Dropbox and a lot of other
great companies were as well or had one
founder who really drove the project
through so I think people who are
willing to go through it solo it's
already hard enough people who can
persevere for like a year or longer by
themselves I really admire that you can
you can kind of I mean the reference is
in some sense like you know like if you
ask people like you know who are the
best people you ever worked with and
they name someone that's probably
someone who's pretty good as a technical
person do you vet the product like the
tech side of it and all yes but I kind
of believe and I'm stealing a lot of
this from Marc Andreessen but that a
really strong team in a really great
market will eventually build the right
product and like will they'll figure it
out like because the market will drag
the right product out of them whether
they whether it's kicking and screaming
like docker came out of DOC cloud you
know there's lots of ins that twitch
came out of justin.tv
justin.tv was actually had this one
vertical like gaming that was really
growing and they actually ditched the
rest of it and just did the gaming
vertical and so often like good markets
will actually good growing markets will
actually eventually steer you in the
right direction so as an investor have
you been burned yet I mean you've only
been doing it for a couple years right
are there any like hard lessons you've
had to learn I think one good thing well
I think people complain evaluations
every single year I've heard this since
2005
I remember when Optimizely seed round
was at 4 and people were like that's so
expensive I'm never gonna pay that like
you know now it's probably good it's my
multi-billion dollar company so I don't
listen to that anymore I think a lot of
the best deals can feel expensive as
Gary tan recently said you kind of
investors make their money basically on
being on being the deal everyone wants
to be in or being in the deal nobody
wants to be in and I think that's
largely true like if you look at like
say Dropbox and Airbnb they took it like
over a year to go from demo day to their
series day so that you don't have to
actually rush into things at demo day
there's a lot of room in the post seed
world where you can kind of invest like
maybe I had a slightly higher valuation
but like before the series there and so
I've done a lot of that as well
and how are you finding those deals
there are either often their products I
use or often there's things that
actually solve problems that I had like
and like in terms of areas I focus on I
guess I should especially mention a lot
of b2b and like enterprise a lot of
autonomous vehicle tech and a lot in
like marketplaces I'm still bullish on
like on I don't think that there are
enough marketplaces for all the
different verticals yet hmm
like for example okay I'm an investor in
courtsey which is actually which is a
great startup just did their Series B
and they are bringing for for life
science laboratories like at
universities or say like Genentech
they're very they're uniting like
they're fixing the whole like inventory
system problem like because most folks
just have like either like a chalkboard
with like writing down what they have or
like whatever or like some paper binder
so they are uniting the life science
labs with the suppliers and that's very
valuable and much like Airbnb like a lot
of people set up with like well why do
we need Airbnb
we already have Craigslist but often
these these experiences are much better
when they're custom tailored yeah yeah I
think it was Chris Dixon who like made
that graphic a while ago of like
breaking Craigslist out into like all
these billion-dollar companies is
something like that yeah no I think it's
true it's there's so many companies that
are just like we see with YC and I think
Jarrod actually wrote a post about it
last year the startup zeitgeist like all
the trends like people often don't pay
attention to the unsexy but like giant
markets yeah and those are often like
the most interesting ones in terms of
like investments and so a lot of my
investments didn't didn't seem sexy at
the time but but worked out and so like
where are the markets you think that
like people in addition to those
marketplaces like people ought to be
paying attention to because right now
there's a lot of noise around you know
say for example like VR or machine
learning AI stuff do you think that
those things are are worth startups
going for right now or are there other
things that you think are good good
opportunities yeah so I actually really
like existing huge markets that are
growing this is not not everyone agrees
with this some people say look for a
small market and like expand it like I
think that's kind of I think I think in
0 to 1 Peter teal kind of talks about
this fact that certainly can work but I
think a lot of Dropbox is like a great
example a lot of famous investors I
won't name past on Dropbox at a 2
million dollar valuation saying the
space is too crowded but when you see a
huge market that's fragmented with like
lots of like companies that many were
public already doing the same kind of
thing just badly if you can make a 10x
better product like you can really win
and there's room for lots of winners
right boxes public based you know they
started like roughly in the same like
era you know Dropbox is doing really
really well I think they just hate a
billion dollar or a run right or
something and there's room for lots of
winners in huge markets and so I I'm
guilty of following like trends and like
saying like Oh YouTube is hot let's do
like YouTube for X like oh like don't
cruise wrecks do that yeah
because that that that's rarely how the
best companies were formed
like when strike started everyone said
why another payments company everyone
already has a payment system but they
made a 10x better product that
developers loved they found an initial
who loved what they were doing developer
friendly and they signed version IDs on
the fly that was huge
Dropbox had like the same kind of
reaction every and B I mean as SciVal
posted like you know all the famous
investors passed on that like because
they didn't really uh well they didn't
necessarily understand the problem like
you know why would I rent out the living
room of my brownstone in Manhattan
I don't you know do you think it is an
education problem because that happens
with YC a lot right like there there are
people that are seemingly entering a
crowded space but in actuality like they
are going to be the winner right so if
you are the founder of that company how
do you educate people if you do in fact
need money from them like what do you is
it or is it just about education I think
YC is actually like done a really
admirable job in just picking relentless
individuals like the Airbnb got like the
Airbnb team which was like a team that
just was never gonna give up and even
when they're not sure about the market
or idea they'll bet on really amazing
people who are relentless and I think
that's one of the genius parts of life
seen YYC has worked out so well
I suspect nowadays I think you kind of
have to ship at least part of that 10x
better product just because the
application that nowadays I don't think
I what you can get into YC oh if I have
fled right now but because it's much
harder to get into there's just more
applications now than there were back
then and so I think if you can show some
traction or some product market fit in a
large market that's always good but in
terms I mean I just think investors or
well I think a lot of investors are
wrong on this and I think a great way to
find startup ideas is to look at the Inc
500 magazine you know and they shows the
fastest growing startups like in terms
like revenue like like say like
year-over-year or like over three years
and then just look at those markets and
then see if you have founder market fit
in any of them do you know any of those
markets really well
and then if you you know have a secret
as Peter Thiel would say like if you
know something about like if like like
much like the way like Drew knew that
you know we can make a much better
backup cloud storage type product like
than this and like it's ridiculous
people are using USB drives for backing
up stuff like and that's because all
products suck even though there are
public companies in this space and
that's so he just sat down and built the
10x better product so I I really like
looking at the software that you use
every day and seeing which ones annoy
you
like which ones make you like really
cringe and I always write those down
because if you're using that means it's
probably one of the better products or
it's what people are forced to use and
if you can build the 10x better product
people will switch totally and I think
paying attention to market size makes a
huge difference I'm I'm still shocked
that there aren't more like not crews
the look-alikes but self-driving in
general like personal transportation is
so massive that like there's room for
like ten of them yes Sebastian Thrun
recently was I think he was quoted
saying basically roughly a self-driving
like kind of like engineer type person
is worth roughly like ten million
dollars so like in like in that position
or like in like M&A I mean I mean cruise
was fifty people and sold for a billion
but keep in mind GM stock price actually
went up on the news so like the market
actually I think viewed it viewed this
positively because GM what rate well GM
wisely noted that they were gonna either
become a software in technology company
or kind of become a dinosaur relic
because I believe it but this is true of
all companies like all companies will
either become software companies or
they're gonna die as an investor now do
you have just a fear of choosing the
right idea if you were to do a start-up
again like are you scared we're doing
one or would you want to that's such
such a great question
and I that's okay yes absolutely
and I actually think repeat founders or
something that's actually a disadvantage
in many ways because you feel this
pressure to come up with some genius
idea when usually the best startups are
not a genius idea they're not some
brilliant flash in the pan it's just
doing something that like Facebook
MySpace were
existed Friendster had already existed
but like Mark just really nailed it he
started with colleges he doesn't it
awesome that people loved and so I I
think often just doing things better is
like not a bad strategy
but the second time founder I for a
third time founder I feel a pressure to
like it's like the sophomore slump that
Richard Fineman talks about in physics
where he wasn't allowed to work on small
ideas anymore he had to work on some
gigantic thing but all the best
discoveries and physics came from like
kind of hide that doesn't seem right
like you know it's kind of odd that
Maxwell's equations say that like you
know speed of light is always constant
so what do you do to like actively
combat that in your brain and just the
people around you as well I think you
have to I almost want to say like now
not work in secret but like I wouldn't
even talk up too much about my idea
probably because I'm so stupid but the
best I think the best companies do sound
like kind of done and also being willing
to experiment with lots of kind of dumb
ideas and maybe focusing on markets
where there already is the so-called
winner I think there's room for lots of
winners and lots of markets it's really
tough to because I know I knew tons of
successful people that work on all these
little side projects but are embarrassed
to put them out because they're just
like stupid little toys and like you
know it would be I don't know
inappropriate or just not cool for them
to put out some like Chrome extension
yeah they just built for themselves and
then this actually gets worse then you
kind of get tempted to like take the
money people offer you because like
whatever in fundraising you're like okay
I'll take a couple million dollars just
like as a seed round but then you're
suddenly almost stuck in whatever market
and product that you kind of picked and
you've probably picked wrong just like
we did just like I did every time so
knowing that you've picked wrong like
you kind of get stuck in it's too
awkward to tell your investors that
you're changing and pivoting and so I
think second time founders raise money
to fast but I'm not gonna raise money
until I have strong product markets it
and I know what I'm doing
and a friend of mine who actually raised
money too early was just lamenting how I
probably killed his second company man
and what about those people who were
successful and then decided that they
want to like create a like a lab where
they have like seven startups and then
to their own yeah that's like really
interesting right like max max legends
done really well with that I kid Yelp
come out of that slide which he sold to
Google you know I think a firm and then
there's some great ones that that models
really worked out for him feel like he's
an outlier yes but I don't know it's
Canberra the other labs I don't think
I've seen be as successful like I think
like Y Combinator used to not like being
called an incubator because like these
most incubators haven't really worked
out that well maxes aside I think it's
hard to really honestly focus on that
many different ideas that are all in
progress
I mean landing pages are one thing what
because they're because they're all the
same template you're modifying text
effectively like often but like if ya
building out having teams that are
working on like six seven different
projects it's hard to figure out that
that really strong product market fit
which is what most startups fail let's
start sale because they'd never get
strong product market fit agreed okay so
kind of like wrapping up if you as a
multi time founder if you were to give
some advice to someone who is starting
their first company what would you tell
them in terms of like don't spend time
doing this spend time doing that this is
- a first time founder uh why don't we
do both like so first time and second
time or whatever everything that's not
working on your product and finding
product market fit is a waste of time
look it's the only thing that you should
be doing don't don't worry about
fundraising don't worry about everything
else if you know the folks who do
fundraise too early typically get into
real trouble because they never are able
to get the product market fit really
focus on finding that huge market go to
go to that Inc 5000 lists find the
fastest-growing companies find a market
that you know really really well but
better better than anyone else
so have founder market fit
and like make it a big one that's
growing and then just build a 10x focus
on building a 10x better product in that
space
you